okay Warren we're going to let me use TL
Warren we're going to address your
question now so
here we'll just do this first part we
have some guests tonight so we just get
everyone in the ball
[Music]
part we're just looking at UK right now
okay all right let's try that so kind of
TI this class with the last class don't
don't have the io cances so we'll give
you something to do I'm the UK so move
off that okay so
my attack is here and we'll do a ten con
into the
T up
okay let's try it careful on the throws
go out the speed your
take um the throw is not an acceleration
throw it might seem like that but it's
not okay so as you come around you're
going to use his Heels by this downward
pressure to pin his legs so you're not
taking them like that
you have to feel the weight of his heels
it's right there and once they're pinned
with his weight that's when you
throw so there's a downward this there's
a check right there okay and run from
you get his ankles pinned that's where
you do the pull
back okay let's try it again
Lear is you're going to do the first
part you're going to come here you're
going to get a hold of the wrist okay
he's not countering or anything but now
he's not he's going to resist okay
that's what he's going to do and now you
have to move into that other
stance when you move into that other
stance you're going to have to shift
your weight so you can
ground on the foot and you can get your
legs strengthening there so if I'm
coming around this side my weight's
going to shift onto my left foot and I
bring that left foot into a positive
angle on the knee do it
again boom boom shift now that foot can
move my leg move my leg move me move him
okay five
if you pay
attention everyone change your
Technique here ground
right ground then you move it seems
subtle but what you're trying to
avoid is that you went like
this okay that is something that happens
but it's not something I do as l i just
here so he comes around we do that first
drill again and he just comes behind me
I I been countered anything it's because
I counter that he'll come around and
take that step I haven't countered
anything that's where he wants to be
that's what we're working okay so no
counter on my part what I mean by that
is I'm not stepping or doing anything
just letting UK do this boom counter no
boom boom that's all we're doing right
now okay try it again okay so now I do
something so and what I do is not try to
make myself strong and pull against him
okay I try to find the in space so he
wants to cut that hand down and bring it
here where he can eventually pull it
backwards so what I do is a 90°
fluctuation to his angle of attack and
it goes
into y space there's nothing there even
though we're touching there's nothing
there and I start to open up his back
corner almost like you're now going to
the back of him
okay I just do it at a rate that this
reaches neutral
y then I use the other hand to bait
him so the other hand is there and I
bring him forward and that's what starts
to St
one I give it to him and then bring him
in keep your hands in front of you yes
in with spiral
[Music]
yes neutral y face
neutral
B okay let's try it go in the movement
of our two
bodies I moving inside of
him go
back so I heeld on the circle and then
I'm moving inside again you guys got
that
okay don't come this way and go forward
inside the hand then I go this
way just look at my body we get the work
for now and I'm
this to do that you can bring him around
further but if I make him Chase it like
a
dog like a border calling on the ball it
doesn't really do anything do you get it
you're like over here who's going to do
that you get it so you just stay
enough where he has it but doesn't have
it does that make sense so boom
boom very
soft
circles un
knock inside
with with a
bit okay let's try again all right so
when I use the the circle the emmer
spiral that's what I do to get his arms
to move inward
spiral we're just looking at the first
arm okay where are you Cam so I can't be
back here cuz that's his technique but
because I yielded how I did it stays in
front now what I do is the inward
spiral as I turn my
qua over here
go it's the first one
just my hand's going like this just like
the de nugget
trist go
one and just like you even
up okay try it go I use that bait hand
but to L
effect just need him
to get stay there please let go see how
that shoulder is now down okay that's
all I need that's all I need with this
big
[Music]
hand I'm not giving it to him trying to
force this back and doing this kind of
stuff okay it's all seemless very soft
so this hand this hand's going to do a
award spiral too stay there please so
this hand in it's inmer spiral helps
point that elbow down which helps bring
that shoulder down so don't stay here
turn
it two in
spirals okay let's try
it all right so now we go right to the
body so this you can see that his little
rip there doesn't do isn't going to stop
that
okay just come up and and hold
it I have to move my body in the
[Music]
place we just work on thei but I I touch
okay let's try
nice
and going to go right in
here but your arm goes this way
and then I let you
[Music]
go okay try so you guys are going TR
this we call this the X okay but it's a
spiral rotating X okay so we're going to
get you in the ball so here we go you're
the you're the
slow down so I can coach nice and
slow nice and slow okay cool now what we
want on his arm is his arm to keep going
this way around
us but our leg is going to go that way
and that is the X okay so get there
please and we hold his
elbow hold his elbow with
your inside the folded elbow there you
go and with that
grip it goes subtly around you not a lot
so that it crosses over your knee that's
it let's do it
again nice and slow inter cross that be
ready for the his body breathe out
settle all that stuff we always do
yes one more just like that you know
there's some weight now okay so breathe
out
face okay all
right so now what we're going to do is
we're not going to make it be a
projection but we're going to use the
kazushi that we used to throw okay so uh
don't hurt don't hurt each other okay so
that elbow is going to go this way
around
me my body is going this way and what
I'm going to do is bring this elbow
right underneath my center line that is
when I'll catch this so he has his
grip there's his grip I caught the elbow
I start to enter I bring bring it down
Falls right underneath
me one
two no we
close find KN so the leg and the arm
works
together so you should be able to do
this break here here as we you don't
film the teacher back
right break right
here is what we're looking
for that is
youring of e right there okay so we'll
take it to a tap and we'll stop for hey
let's try War here
body arm right here okay now we have to
tighten up the tendons for the C so I
had to bring my leg in and there's
another lock here right here boom on the
shoulder and then there's another
dislocation here on the whole scapula
mechanism so I kind of release it as I
go let him out of it and we're in the EO
pit
o
[Music]
okay let's try